this is second one no good and Caldwell
pump comes away
a door Bobo Pope layup this time he
banks it in on a foul and the Nuggets
had their first lead of the game and
just an all-around struggle again for
the Lakers and I I hate to keep harping
on it but I'm gonna harp this team State
and they don't need him here in the
Conference Finals
he all could spin finds Caldwell pulp
hunting
drive
careful now five to shoot back cut
[Applause]
Humphreys around everybody missed it
here comes yokich
dumping Harris yes
[Music]
gracious let's get some stuff folks
jokic will shoot no he'll give it
together
has his 11th Double-Double in the last
12 games
he's over six from the field he has only
those two free throws
Joker looked away and
your husband oh man a three for Barton
what a no-look touch pass by yoki's man
Jackson is there behind the bat jokic's
thinking three
Good Feet inside and he finds the
cutting Gordon for two but last night in
the NBA what a one
oh beautiful behind
us out of a hop from Millsap the
offensive player
Barton no jokic paddling what a battle
yoga oh my goodness what a dish
third rebound for blue arrow over the
top three on the back end left
Nelson letting it fly
Woodland Target was way short the Rob
upstairs to Fareed
sidesteps for three
three
can the Nuggets get a stop Porter Jr
that's all fjokitch has it baseball pass
Porter's out there and he puts it away
they leaked out on the shot challenge
a floppy floater flew out of bounds
water polo pass Beasley score wow wow
how about that for your 10th assist
speaking of confidence Ingles had that
Rim halfway down and out the long pass
complete to Grant touchdown Denver
tickets go along
he does Murray shot good at the ghost
get that one year Scott when you shot a
hundred percent look at this
yes they're getting after every loose
ball
jokic oh behind the head no look passed
yes
doubles
behind the back
his his down here is gonna be what can
he do there
come on now Joker over the shoulders
[Music]
[Applause]
shot that ball with a lot of confidence
you could tell by his body language
[Music]
can't be Stars
without
space to do their thing oh what a touch
pass what's up there's that zone again
volleyballs it to Najee nice tip there
oh nice pass by the Joker
on this possession
jokic backs him down Gordon underneath
slams it down somehow found some space
return at the base
another rebound jokic has a
double-double his 18th oh no
passing kcp a slider from mid Court way
off the market has it so Minnesota
passed oh what a pass threat to needle
baby Nicola jokic
Tobias Harris nice shot in the paint
good look wouldn't go great look at this
guy oh
pass some green throws it down the cup
yeah Sacramento trying to drive in
there's jokets that man again jokic with
the block shot his second tonight
[Applause]
away they got a long pass to jokic
behind the back to Porter nicely done
I didn't say by Jokers maybe that'll get
powering it up no jokic has it there's a
reset on the 20. oh
my gosh oh my goodness Lyle scores
the Denver team that he's made the
playoffs three straight years
just been completely destroyed by
injuries though some of the big names
follicle Superior
halfway through our first quarter yoka
China to get that pass through there oh
man that 22 games now where he's been in
double figures a good player
jokic coming in over the shoulder to
Gordon what a beauty
looking forward to the playoffs possibly
and possibly playing against the
Warriors in the first round
[Applause]
50.
oh good screen by jokic it's just buried
that is behind the back to Chandler it
was actually over the head to Chandler
and a score nine and three at home
[Music]
what did we just see there my goodness